what we're searching for today is very
simple it's the answer to how do we
decode the wonderful codes that we
created just about what a week ago now
something like that let's just remind
ourselves where we were with this code
it was a 5-bit code coding theorists
will talk about this code which I'm
going to write out as being a five to
three program fill in the details and
then I'll refer what I've written down
to this remember also that these are the
exact powers of 2 that's 2 squared the
number 2 position is 2 to the power 1
the number one position last 2 to the
power 0 but that leaves bit 3 and bit 5
for the actual message bits to bits bit
through bit 5 to bits
for combinations possible and those are
the four San Francisco weather states so
as sometimes we refer to these as
infobits message bits it comes to the
same thing
that's the message you're trying to get
across that's the message that these
parity bits are there to check out and
make sure it's ok and we ended up with
one code word if you remember that's the
in phrase for these things the zero zero
state in message terms I think we said
was foggy to stand around and here's the
protection of the parity bits there we
are full written out going now coding
theorists would call this a 5 to 3 code
how does that work well it's a 5-bit
code that's what the first number means
it means total number of bits the 2
means the number of message or
information bits and this if we remember
is this business or the distance how
many bits differ between these rows so
the distance in this technical usage of
the term here the number of bits that
differ between that line and that line
is 3
and to get one of these codes working
you need a minimum distance of three and
what do we mean by working what we mean
is that a distance three code can
correct a one bit error and for those of
you just yelling at me but what's the
general formula then for what you can
correct for a given distance in that
watch carefully
it's a one-liner moral in floor of e
minus one over two and when the floor of
means round down so let's do it for
distance three three - one - two / - one
round down one is already rounded down
so that's telling you using the floor of
function is saying for distance three
you can detect and correct one error so
bearing that in mind if we see things in
the future with different distance
properties at the end which all supply
this to find out how many things they
could correct the powers of two when the
parity check bits what sequence of
numbers were they used in checking up on
this first block the one bit checks
itself and three and five two-bit checks
itself and three and the four bit checks
four and five where do those come from
how do you get those lists and I think
last time I perhaps didn't make this
quite crystal clear so let me explain
that those come from effectively saying
for all of the things that aren't powers
of two how could you build them up from
adding together powers of two one you
don't have to build it up that's itself
one is one similarly two is a power of
two and it's just itself where you
really have to start doing this powers
of two add them together to build them
up thing is with three the most compact
way to represent three sums of powers
- is 1 + 2 what about 4 no problem for
is itself it's a power of 2 but then
when you get 5 you say are the most
compact way to do this is 1 plus 4
powers of 2 6 2 + 4 7 quite complicated
now if you think about it sum of powers
of 2 that add up to 7 in the most
compact way you can do it on + 2 + 4 so
really these lists that we had
previously about what checks for what is
a result of writing these out first and
then say but if we were going backwards
where does the digit 1 appear it appears
in itself it appears in the formula for
3 it's been in the formula for 5 it
appears in the formula for 7 so that's
where that first list came out here that
one checks up on 1 3 5 7 9 11 all the
odd numbers because one would appear in
the sums of powers of 2 that build those
up - yes - appears obviously in its own
list but it appears first of all next
door in 3 has been 1 plus 2 disappearing
fall no falls all on its own as opposed
to what about 5 would to appear in 5 no
it's one too small so the next place
that two would appear is 6 which is 2
plus 4 so I hope if you so if you have a
6-bit code would to have to check on on
1 X 2 a bit yes it would
similarly for checks on four it checks
on 5 is also checks on 6 because 6 is 2
plus 4 so if you're building up these
lists making them longer to do more
complex codes then if you're encoding
and decoding in this by hand method you
need to keep up to date your sums of
powers of 2 for all the new positions
unless their exact path of do and then
go backwards and say ha but these are my
checklists that I build up
that so just to remind you then of what
happened was that on this one here let's
say the second one the informational
message bits are zero and one
but it tells us here must be three and
bit five this is here the bits one three
and five taken together must be even
well three and five normal one add them
together that's one
so therefore bit one which we will be
filling in has to be want make it even
we're going to say because you all want
to know how to decode it and detect
errors and correct them this one here is
going to be badly transmitted instead
are one zero zero one one it is received
as one zero one one one
so straight away whoever gets that is
going to say that isn't right they're
going to say that that isn't right
because there's so few of these there's
only four of them you get to know them
like old friends but you imagine if
you've got 64 of the sound cells can you
guarantee that you'll be able to
memorize every single one no you need an
algorithm and what we do here is a
reverse of what we did when we encode it
we say let's look at the list that
follows on and is checked from one one
three five and so on that's what we
received that one is one bit 3 is 1 1 on
1 is 0 bit 5 is 1 0 & 1 is 1
ah it's supposed to be even parity wrong
it came out as odd parity bit two checks
out on itself and on bit three it
doesn't clear a bit 5 because 5 is 1
plus or not 10 plus 4 so you look at
bits 2 and bits 3 0 exclusive old or
added
if you like to want it's a world it's
odd parity it's wrong ok now you look at
the four bit and you say bit four checks
out 4 & 5 4 & 5 1 and
it's zero hooray it passed the test
yeah we fell two tests we can work out
from that now yes you can the rock very
simply because the headers of these
lists are the powers of two that they
check up on in all of those lists and if
the two one is gone wrong the one one
has gone wrong then the wrong bit was
one plus two ordinary addition this time
not binary addition one and two mix
three bit three is wrong so then we flip
bit three we go right ahead three one
zero one one one that's the bad bit it's
received as a one it's wrong so it must
have been a zero one zero zero one one
magic does that look familiar
that's what you correct it back to and
it's entirely done by getting these
lists of powers of two doing another
check on them almost like it's exactly
the same as when you were n coding it's
just you're doing this again
hey pick that up
see you simply reverse the process I
mean Oh does that always work yes for
any of those bits the Parenti of this
part now that's a good thing if you if
you're thinking all but that's a message
bit oh no come on something really went
wrong there because what was transmitted
is zero one that Sonny wasn't it has
turned out as mm Webber rainy one one
one on it he turns rainy
oh yeah that's fine but what's not if he
hits a parity bit surely that messes
everything up no it isn't essentially
dead easy and I want to leave as an
exercise for you to do is at this time
one zero zero one one don't hit a
message bit hit that parity bit at
fishin for change it to zero do the
checks and you'll find out that the
wanna list passes with flying colors
nothing wrong with it the to list passes
with flying colors the only one that
fails is the for list so if it's the
only one that fails that's it for is for
nothing twenty you've done the homework
for so I've done the homework but yeah
so do it for yourself on any bit you
like and convince yourself
this message little parity bit this
method will come in on it I have built
this up I never explain to you now you
can go into a pub full of coding
theories and say hey like I've got this
five to three code and they will say
well you realize that you derived it
using Richard Hammonds algorithm but is
not a true proper Hamming code because
it's not perfect and you say perfect
what's perfect I think we have to go to
another video Sean I know they hate
Cliff Agnes but yes real Hamming codes
are perfect like really are now the only
sort of if you like slide health warning
to say about this just to round this off
now is by all means do it by hand if you
want to code it up as a program great
you'll learn a lot but don't run away
with the idea that this is the most
efficient way to do it